besoin de santé évoluent et personne ne
peut plus supporter que des
établissements se fassent une
concurrence nuisible et on le sait bien
et beaucoup des débats sont crispés
autour de cette fameuse tarification à
l'activité
on a eu des bas d'ailleurs pour la
pédiatrie en fin d'année en disant faut
revaloriser et au fond c'est une logique
exclusive dans la tarification à l'acte
qui a
créé beaucoup de
faut le dire de dysfonctionnement dans
le système d'abord parce que
il y a une partie du système privé ou
privée non lucratif qui coopère
formidablement et je les en remercie et
ici d'ailleurs vous avez très bien très
bons exemples il y a aussi certains
établissements qui coopèrent pas du tout
c'est une réalité
le mode de rémunérations qu'on a créé ne
valorise que l'acte et donc enfin un
extrême majorité on le sait très bien il
prend mal en compte le soin non
programmé il prend mal en compte les
activités les plus complexes qui vont
prendre du temps la pédiatrie étant un
très bon exemple mais il y en a d'autres
et au fond il laisse le cœur des
activités qui se retrouvent à l'hôpital
public aussi parce que beaucoup d'autres
ne veulent plus les faire
et donc
je vais pas vous dire on va sortir
progressivement de la T2A il se trouve
parce que ça je l'ai déjà dit en
novembre 2018 donc j'ai le sens de la
fois du ridicule l'esprit de
responsabilité quand des systèmes se
sont installés et qu'on dit on va les
changer progressivement ça ne marche pas
donc il faut qu'on procède différemment
on doit sortir de la tarification à
l'activité dès le projet dès le prochain
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour aller vers un
nouveau financement qu'on doit rebâtir
sur le base d'un travail en profondeur
et d'une concertation qui repose sur une
rémunération basée sur des objectifs de
santé publique
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que pour l'hôpital public les
établissements privés les professionnels
de santé dans le libéral faut qu'il y
ait une part
structurante de la rémunération qui
repose sur des objectifs de santé
publique on négocie à l'échelle d'un
territoire
et qui comment on prend en charge la
population qui nous est donnée ça crée
plus de coopération et c'est la réalité
de ce que vivent les territoires ensuite
il doit y avoir une rémunération
effective des missions réalisées par
chacun
prise en charge de la mission et de sa
complexité et enfin une part de
rémunération à l'activité qui est tout à
fait légitime et qui doit continuer
d'être là
ce chantier il faut absolument le faire
parce que c'est celui qui permettra de
recréer de la coopération davantage
entre le public et le privé de mieux
prendre en compte les spécialités qui
sont les plus complexes qui sont parfois
les parents pauvres et surtout de créer
plus de coopération vous allez me voir
venir à l'échelle des territoires c'est
exactement ce qu'on veut faire
ce nouveau financement concernera tout à
la fois les établissements publics et
privés mais aussi la rémunération de la
coopération entre la ville et l'hôpital
pour favoriser le travail collectif au
service des patients
[Musique]